when captain Tom Moore began walking
around his garden he never imagined what
would happen next
the first card arrived at Easter and
since then the birthday wishes have kept
coming we are utterly humbled by it I
cannot thank people enough for their
support more than a hundred and twenty
thousand cards are being kept at captain
Tom's grandson's school and sorting
through them is busy work speaking
pretty crazy it's been a lot of five air
and wake up's and 1 a.m. sleeps been
eating about 11 o'clock at night I mean
it's crazy but it's a hell of an
experience
we got about 20,000 a day from the post
office they all get sent in then they
bring lorries in and crates and carry
them up the stairs and here they are now
in the midst of lockdown it was a
personal challenge that became a
national triumph ninety nine year old
captain Tom raised twenty nine million
pounds and Counting walking up and down
his garden a hundred times and as the
donations rise so to his support it's
overwhelming a hundred and fifty
volunteers are sorting through his
birthday cards the very best will be
brought to him and the rest of filling
what was once a school Hall we've opened
cards from two-year-olds who are just
learning to scribble and there's a few
lines on them 290 some things every card
is genuinely heartwarming to to open
it's been a pleasure to do so it's just
as well I think that he he asked us to
do it because they'd certainly couldn't
have hid it in his run room I don't
think it's not just a number of cards
here that's extraordinary it's the fact
that you've got cards coming from places
like Lancashire and the Falklands people
up and down the country young and old a
rallying to support Captain Tom it's
brought people together at a very
strange time it will take captain Tom
some time to get through these once
lockdown is over until then he's given
us all someone to cheerful and something
we'll remember when all of this is over
ally Fortescue Sky News